hello everyone and welcome back to day
two of the Magnus Carlsen
sorry round 2 of the Magnus Invitational
with a really wild game between Yaya me
she and the maxime beaugeois Grove and
well when either of them is playing you
know it's gonna be a crazy game but when
the two of them are playing against each
other well that can only mean one thing
and let's check it out
so Knepper opens the with c4 he goes for
the English and we have c6 by Maxine
going for the sort of a caro-kann
defense against the English with Knight
to f3 d5 and g3 now they're preparing to
fianchetto the light square Bishop
Knight to have sex with Bishop Bishop to
g2 and now D captures and C for
preparing to now expand on on the Queen
side if possible maybe even defend some
of those pawns but first we have castles
and now Knight B to d7
we have 9th to a3 now going after those
pawns and nights the b6 of course
defending the c4 pawn for as long as
possible white wants to reclaim at Queen
c2 goes after the pawn and Bishop to e6
now now defending it and now we go into
one of the crazier lines that there are
interest Knight to g5 challenges the
bishop here now threatens the to mess up
even the pawn structure in the center of
the board Bishop to g4 putting pressure
on a 2 and now Knight captures on c4 and
here we have the the very interesting
Bishop captures on e2 now with a double
attack under rook and under night and
Knights the e5 now threatening to pick
up the f7 pawn offering the rook on f1
but the problem is if Bishop captures
first you recapture the bishop and
you're still gonna capture here so
that's not really an option for black so
instead we have Bishop back to h5 by nvl
now defending the f7 pawn and here there
are a few games in the database that
reach this position where Knight to h3
was played and also there is there is
one game where Knight to e4 was played
but here net would just plays Knight
characters on f7
and sorry not with that night but with
this knife he plays Knight he captures
on f7 no he doesn't
sorry about that first after Knight to
h5 he played rook to e1 forgot about
that one and only after Maxime attacked
it with h6 now comes in Knight and G
captures on f7 and here it's it's very
interesting to see where the
compensation for the sacrifices but you
will see soon enough bishop characters
and now before now preparing to push b5
to to attack here on c6 and bust open
the position and the compensation is
white has a lot of developed pieces this
Knight really putting a grip on the
Kings position here and you have many
more moves to make before you finish
development and castle the King to
safety so a six preventing b5 and now
just a four by nipple and here the
problem is it's not easy to develop for
example if you try something like e six
to get your Bishop into the game
immediately you'll get Knight capture
screen captures and a Bishop to h3
going after this pawn and black will
have a very hard time defending this and
also interesting I think to note never
played all of these moves pretty much
instantly so this is a prepared line
from him with g5 by maksim now preparing
to fianchetto the dark square bishop
this way and Bishop the a3 by net for
again pretty much played instantly we
have Bishop to g7 and now the black king
is ready to castle but neppo doesn't
allow it Knight to g6 now and again what
do you play here you could ignore the
knight but maxim decides to bravely
capture it so Bishop captures we have
Queen captures with Czech and now King
to f8 and Napo just continues with b5 so
what do you do here we have night but B
to d5 centralizing this night be
captures and c6 will be captures and c6
now defending the knight on d5 twice and
rook a to be one nipple wants to shift
to this rook over to f3 to help out with
the attack against the black king so we
have Queen to d7 preparing to bring the
other Brooke into the game and now comes
Luke the b3 as planned and here we have
King to g8 and this is a very important
move for Maxime a crucial defensive move
if you will for example if you make
I'm moving like rook to e8 let's say you
play something like this you immediately
lose the Bishop character sandy 5c
captures and outlook the f3 with too
many threats for a black superior
because the rook captures here is a
threat you will not be able to recapture
because of this this pencil this is
off-limits and that there is no good
defense against this even if you move
the King still rook captures wins
because now you can recapture but now
just characters captures and captures
wins the game pretty much pretty much
instantly as now it's a it's a queen
against the rook so King to g8
incredibly important move by Maxime now
rook to b8 rook to f3 will be a bit more
bearable
so rook eat the b1 now going after rook
to b8 check and now Quinta eh preventing
that while also offering to trade Queens
a nipple has to go back with the Queen
now and now comes Luke to h7 so somehow
Maxime will try and and get those pieces
into the game and maybe maybe even this
rook so better back the b2 and now
Bishop the f8 removing the bishop and
not allowing this straight to happen
after the knight moves so Bishop to e5
by nepo and now Knight to d7 threatening
to capture the bishop and here nipple
could have tried it could have tried
some other moves for example Bishop the
e4 is an idea going after the rook here
but nepo decided to just eliminate the
d5 Knight and grab at least a pawn so
this comes with check C captures Queen
captures with check and now ecigs
blocking an epic win has to go back and
we reach this position after rook to f7
where nepo is up a pawn but he is down a
knight and you know there is a there is
a thing in chess that fisheries fischer
by the night is a night and here nipple
will have a very hard time playing
against this night so he was for Bishop
to d6 he doesn't want to give up Bishop
for a knight now so he offer he offers a
trade of dark square bishop we have
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
quinta east 7 as MVL is a upper piece of
course he will very much enjoy trading
Queens which nip of course declines
Queen to c6 and now rook a
the f8 going after the F do pawn so now
if you don't want to play something
incredibly passive to defend that pawn
which you shouldn't do you have to play
extremely active moves you've sacrificed
for the attack
so rook the e3 he goes after the e6 pawn
but maxime just captures an f2 he
doesn't care about east 6 we rope
captures on e6 and now Queen to f7 and
now you have to really figure out what
to do here with white rook the g6 seems
like a reasonable idea however after
Kington h7 or even king to each it you
can even give up the pawn once the King
comes to g7 there's there's not too much
you can do to continue the attack and
the rook to f1 is coming so neppo
instead try to Queen to b4 now well he
might have some some ideas here if he
can get out of this rook to f1 threat
maybe maybe you can go for something
like rook here or maybe rope to g6 in
the future to try something but it's
very hard to do here rook to f1 actually
wins for maxime but he was a very long
time and he didn't he didn't feel like
calculating it for example of course you
don't capture Queen captures would be
make you have to move the king and then
after Queen f2 check you go to h3 and
now it it's a winning position for Black
Knight to f6 is the best here but even
if you're not sure you can just trade
Queens here and well just enjoy an
Indian being a piece up but instead we
have Knight to f6 by mvo first bringing
the knight into the game and now queen
the c4 not allowing the queen to move as
nipple would have a lot of nasty
discoveries here so rook the f3 now your
look is also under attack so rook to f3
we have a King to g2 attacking it and
the g4 now just cementing that rook on
f3
we have rook beat the b6 now and now
King to h8 so the King on pins now the
Queen can move you won't have any
discoveries here and here nipple should
probably play rook captures on a6 and
just hope for the best
he now has a passed pawn maybe he can
somehow trade Queens and play on that
passed pawn but it would still be
incredibly hard because Queen h5
threatens Queen h3 King g1
switch to King Queen to a5 again it's
gonna be incredibly difficult to defend
but it perhaps was the best try however
never went for h3 and now you are Maxine
here there is actually a forced
checkmate in eight here and when I say
for checkmate in eight I mean eight with
the best possible defense from white of
course white is white is allowed to
defend poorly so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the rook
sacrifice with rook captures and g3 and
for those of you who just won in your
show what I just said so look at person
g3 and you have some options here for
example if you capture the rook which is
something you might consider
then comes Knight to e4 with check King
goes back Alexa King to g2 although you
could you could even go to h4 but we are
going to cover that and now it's just
going to have to with checking each one
and night the g3 with mate and if you
don't go with the King after 94 check if
you go to h4 it doesn't really matter
Queen to F to check once again you're
gonna go to h5 now comes Queen to f5
check you have to go either down or up
up the board doesn't really matter and
now it's going to g5 again with
checkmate
so after rook captures in g3 you might
try the cleaning it but then a black
just continue sacrificing of course you
can decline once again rook g3 check you
could decline once again but now there's
a there's no h-bond
kind of reminiscent of it of the time
its vs. Bardot Laban game where you
continue sacrificing the rock until you
eliminate D H pawn and now Queen to h5
with check forcing you to capture and
now finally 94 check captures or doesn't
really matter and Queen to h3 will be
made as the rook prevents the King from
reaching the DF file so it was in the
position however Maximo one time he
didn't he didn't want to calculate all
that much instead he went for Knights -
h7 first just not allowing this to come
with check so you don't really care
about the h6 pawn
next you're gonna go rook to f2 check so
here Napo without any options decided to
trade Queens and take this into an
so check Queen g7 not Queen f6 obviously
Queen captures and g7 with check King
captors and rookie 7 check now King to
h8 and the now comes Luke - e - you
don't have time to grab upon as you're
running into mate here after King G -
look F 2 is checkmate so look back to e
2 by nipple not allowing this check but
now G captures on h3 King captures in
rook 3 back to f6 not allowing the
capture of the a6 pawn so rugby 7 hoping
that maybe you can get rook to e7 in and
now rook to g6 instead and here we have
worked the e7 if you go for rook to a7
if you go for a rook to e7 right away
then just Knight g5 check and the knight
will always cover the h7 square so look
the a7 instead but now Knight g5 with
check again King G - and now rook jitta
f6 just again with full control of the F
file and keeping an eye on the a6 pawn
so d4 we have rook a to the f7 now
offering a trade here rotate check and
now King to g7 and neppo continues to
push his only passport so d5 we have
looked at b7 putting group in front of
the passport and they prod us the
opposite he puts the row behind the pass
pawn rook after d6 it goes after it and
now just g4 so if the rook is capped
if the pony's captured an epic can grab
the a sex pawn so tonight's the efore
first goes after the rook rook the sea
rook the sea - sorry rook to c2 and now
Knight to f6 you still don't want to
capture and allow this capture so just
Knight of 6 who goes after the pawn with
the night but now look the c6 forcing
this capture of the pawn
well you might even consider capturing
and c6 but it gives a white the past
pawn so might not be all that Pleasant
so instead rook characters here and not
rook 8 characters in a sex and at least
now nipa has a past
a pawn so perhaps it is possible to play
this but rook to d2 with check King g3
and now nipple in Napa runs into the
very unpleasant rook to d3 check King f4
we have looked
- with check King has to go to a five
and the now comes looked e - with check
and with rooks having full control of D
and E file the King has to go back but
now you run into Knight to d5 check and
here it was in this position on mu 58
that nipple resigned the game as it is
mating one on the next move of course
you see it after King a5 Luke 2 F 3 will
be checkmate
so nipple did not allow made to be on
the board and after 95 check he resigned
the game which is which is a shame for
those for those who who played the the
fantasy chess League and they said that
there will be a chest made on the board
but you know you can you can't have
everything so that's the game really
really exciting start of the match
between the two of them really crazy
line neppo first time ever that
sacrifice and f7 was played but it is
what we accept expect from Nepal and
neppo always delivers whether he wins or
loses so great a great game by both of
them great start by Maxime we'll see if
nipple can get back into the match I
would like to thank and David chest look
at mr. our little motion Schmoyer
abortion and Mark McNair for conversion
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
invitational so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day